Before you see one single image in the
Lord of the Rings trilogy and you hear a
chorus singing in a somewhat unsettling
harmonic minor key over black,
this is a musical theme that signals the
Loft Florian else.
It's the theme of glad drill,
who's about to narrate the story of the
one ring and prologue,
but not before the rings.
Own feet fades in with the first title
as the prologue ends and an e flat minor
chord shifts to an e flat major.
The narration shifts also from
collateral to Bilbo Sean and the mood
changes.
The lighter shyer theme is introduced as
Bilbo places us there on a map and
finally,
after he places us in time,
the fellowship theme plays in full
statement as its corresponding subtitled
fades in racketing,
the opening of the film.
Now,
if this masterful interplay of themes is
it enough to prove to you already that
composer Howard shore is a genius,
that's okay.
There's a lot more to say.
The first thing is that these four
themes that I've mentioned are actually
what's called light motifs and operatic
technique popularized by Richard Wagner,
that fuses musical themes with specific
people,
events or places to eat,
and in some cases augment the dramatic
development of a story.
In order to show how short develops his
light motifs.
I'm going to isolate one the fellowship
theme,
which has the most variations and focus
on its development in the fellowship of
the ring.
Now before the fellowship theme can come
together in its full heroic glory short,
builds it up with a few variations.
The first time we hear it after the
title is when Frodo and Sam leave.
The Shire on the road to Rivendale short
presents a small snippet of the shyer
theme of foreshadowing of that themes,
final variation at the end of the film,
and then transitions into a humble
statement of the fellowship theme using
just French Horn and core,
and Glen.
It's a dangerous business for them going
out gentle.
This is almost immediately contrasted
with another darker variation as Gandalf
rides into isengard to take counsel with
Sal.
Roma sure adds crashing cymbals and
plays the theme off Gandalf's galloping
horse in this tense variation,
prefigure Sarah Mons eventual portrayal,
and the two versions playing off each
other,
anticipate the eventual fracturing of
the fellowship later in the film.
The next time we hear the theme,
Frodo and the hobbits have accepted
stridor or eric as their temporary
leader.
The fellowship is growing,
so the brass section is growing too.
We started with one French horn.
Now we have three,
but the state lead melody of the student
is upset with the Timpani drumbeat that
adds urgency.
The Fellowship Light Motif doesn't
appear again until after Frodo has been
stabbed by the ring greats as our when
racist to get him to Rivendale.
The fellowship theme mixes with a
Raytheon threatening to overtake it.
The fellowship might dissolve before it
even has a chance to fully
form
at the middle of the film.
The fellowship finally comes together
and sure echoes that by presenting a
string of three fellowship theme
statements in their full orchestration
and full glory.
First as l,
Ron announces the fellowship third as
the fellowship strides heroically away
on own
quest.
But the second one is the most
interesting to me,
just as the fellowship is about to
depart.
Shore softly teases the Shire theme
before eight is overpowered by the
fellowship theme,
suggesting that the hobbits priorities
have shifted and they now have to live
with the consequences of that,
and it ends with a unique harmony on the
second half of the full statement as if
to sow a seed of doubt right into the
middle of the team.
As it comes together,
fellowship,
we're going to get another exciting full
statement in the mines of Moria.
The only time that the nine members of
the fellowship will be an action
together,
but the three,
four time signature of the fellowship is
quickly swallowed up by the five four
time signature of the orcs and from now
on,
after Gandalf is lost,
the fellowship theme will only appear in
fragmented form until the very end of
the trilogy.
Your foods,
for example,
after what's left with the fellowship
departs Laurian.
The theme can only muster violins and
cor.
Anglais and sure has this already weak
variation trampled on as soon as it
starts.
Then as they rest on the shore,
the light motif can't find its footing.
It wanders away from its full expression
as uncertainty and suspicion creep,
been facing these insecure variations on
the theme,
Harold,
the breaking of the fellowship,
first with the death of former,
then with the departure of Frodo and
Sam,
in fact,
short links these two moments with a
severely deflated but poignant rendition
of the light motif that fades into
silence
like the fellowship itself.
The fellowship theme builds to its full
formation and then is deconstructed
until it's only a shell of its former
self.
Shore does this with instrumentation,
with tempo and with harmony,
and he does it for several other light
motifs in the trilogy,
weaving them back and forth and through
one another so that the result is a
complex web that entwines with the
story.
I think that we hardly grasp the
importance of music in film.
It's an invisible layer of pure emotion
that guides us or challenges us or
guides or challenges.
The drama itself and the Lord of the
rings trilogy.
Howard shore gave us perhaps the most
complete and complex exploration of
light motifs in the history of cinema
and the result is a score that says
alive as the world Tokyo gave us.
Hey everybody,
thanks for watching and thank you to
squarespace for sponsoring this video of
you guys who pledge on Patrion
squarespace's just helping to fund this
channel,
keep the nerd writer going,
um,
and they don't interfere and the
content,
which is amazing.
Um,
anyway,
the product is really great,
really sleek professional looking
websites.
If you don't know,
very intuitive,
you don't have to know coding to start
one and you can get a free domain name.
If you sign up for a year,
you can start your free trial
today@squarespace.com.
And if you use the offer code
nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
So yeah,
do it anyway.
Thank you so much.
Squarespace.
You should.